this is the opposite return to be all
right now like you know you haven't
tasted it yet so maybe it'll turn you oh
yeah maybe then I'll just be like oh
yeah I want to I want to hit right now
we are gonna make aphrodisiac sandwiches
I wish Erica would make me food at any
point in time Oh ditto yeah I kind of
believe me aphrodisiacs I guess
oh the go there is goat cheese the goat
cheese should be on everything it's a
red pepper looks hot and I think helps
the removal of clothes you have
chocolate
what time is anyone Gotham she's about
the chocolate life we got some bananas
which are I don't know if they're an
aphrodisiac but they're phallic I don't
know
peppers some peppers peppers maybe like
spice things up don't make me a bad
sandwich make you good at sally's I'm
starting with the bananas because I
think that bananas and chocolate go
really well together
you're not gonna put like something like
I'm gonna put the avocado down because
that would stick now I'm a little going
off the beaten path here my sandwich is
something you could probably like you
gonna be able to purchase like somewhere
one of these like uppity cafes
worst-case scenario they're all off a
tzx and like if I put more of them on
it's probably not gonna do bad she's
mashed up bananas and mixing avocado
into it like it blue I looking at it
makes me want to throw up right now
I mean like I'll eat it because of love
or whatever my sandwich has a lot of
things on it because there are a lot of
components to a relationship I'm gonna
name it bananas about you I'll name my
sandwich it's gotta be sexual I'm gonna
call it a Bay which cuz this my Bay I'm
healed and so this is the Love Boat for
your love let's go
time to die
that was dirty I'm sorry it's good
though it's not I mean like it's not bad
I got enough I was bred so it was fine
fine yeah you like it yeah great
I've never been more attracted to you
right now not necessarily to morning
right I feel like if I had more
chocolate which I've been eating this
whole time maybe like it could happen if
it were a slice of pizza
sure